so thank you very much for the
introduction and the thanks everyone for
attending this final talk in the in the
parallel session so we want to take you
on a journey through our projects at
boville which is about asset management
with computer vision and there are three
things that we want to touch upon first
of all our use case what's the use for
computer vision at global and what can
make such your projects is successful
secondly the models that were using so
we want to give you some insights into
the choices that we made for the
particular models and finally how to
efficiently work with a large corpus of
images so those last two parts will be a
bit more technical so my name is Richard
Bartels and that's yes per we're both
data scientist advantage AI and we're
doing computer vision at code so first a
bit about Colville what is polio pol L
is the largest is the owner of the of
the railway in the Netherlands and so
they own the track but they also only
crossings bridges stations etc and not
only do they own all of this stuff but
they also are responsible for
maintaining it and making sure that
there won't be any delays due to failure
of any of these systems so they'll have
to do asset management and doing
efficient asset management means having
detailed knowledge of the whereabouts of
your assets and of the state of your
assets and how they did this in the past
was in the following way they send
somebody out onto the track to inspect
it by hand well they're a bunch of
downsides for this first one if you send
a person out onto the rail track you
have to stop all the trains from running
otherwise it's kind of dangerous
secondly this person will inspect by
hand and an entrant manually into a
database which is also prone to error so
there are a bunch of ways in which you
could do this more efficiently and
that's why the following thing exists a
video inspection train and this is a
train as being operated twice a year to
cover the entire Netherlands and take
pictures of the track and this prevents
two things right you don't have to send
people out onto the track any more so
then you have to last
time and secondly you could in principle
also analyze these images automatically
and thereby not only do it faster but
also more accurately than a human being
could so just to give you an insight in
the types of pictures that we're dealing
with they look in the following way the
pointer doesn't work on the screen so
I'll just tell you you have detailed
pictures of the track and then their
panoramic pictures of the front and the
back side pictures of the track and zoom
in pictures of the railway track and
we're working with these zoom ins that
you see in the middle and I'll tell you
why in a second so what kind of stuff
could you do with these images of real
railway track first of all we have a lot
of them about 50 million for each
campaign of the Netherlands and you can
find all kinds of stuff in these images
for instance you could localize your
assets like here we see a crossing and
we know its location if we also know the
location of the image secondly you might
want to do more advanced things so maybe
you run through the railway track and
you find this current box and you
actually see that it's broken so you
could tag assets as being broken and
finally you might want to monitor the
state of your assets over time so maybe
you see here this insulation joint and
we see that it has degradation by 25% so
we might want to replace it sometime
soon
and in fact the insulation joint is the
asset that we're working on first only
its localization but also later its
state and we're doing this for two
reasons it's easy to detect on the track
because it's just this horizontal stripe
on the track so from a machine learning
point of view it's easy and secondly it
has very high business value because if
these things failed they can cause
signaling failures which are the main
costs or one of the main causes for
delays so there's very high business
value and knowing where these things are
and at the pole moment pro-roh doesn't
know that very accurately so it's great
working with all of these images and you
can there
of use cases but the most important
thing is also to bring that include the
whole end-to-end process so what we had
to do at first was actually labeled
images because they were not labeled we
had to make sure that the location data
matched to the image was correct then
the fun part starts in training a model
but then you also have to convince a
business that your predictions actually
match other sources and finally make
sure that the information lands at the
place where it's supposed to land in the
database where end-users will be using
it we're responsible for the this entire
process and by now we've covered 40% of
the Netherlands and finishing up with
the last 60% updating this information
so just a brief recap we have a train
covering the Netherlands taking pictures
and finding different assets and we can
do that at koval and thereby creates
some business value so that's that for
the use case now let's switch gears and
move on to computer vision so how do you
analyze or how do we analyze these
images at folio so these are the images
that we're dealing with we have on the
right images of track without an
installation joint on it and on the left
and image with an insulation joint and
we want to classify it doesn't have an
insulation joint or not so the technique
we're using for this is convolutional
neural networks which are used for image
recognition who has worked with these
networks before I see a few hands anyway
I'll go through them a little bit just
to make sure we're all on the same page
so convolutional neural network is a
neural network that consists out of a
bunch of convolutional layers and a
bunch of dense layers at the end which
try to classify what image what class
this image belongs to so convolution
works in the following way let's say we
have an image in blue and we have a
filter in gray moving over the image
this filter is applied at each part of
the image and out will come a filtered
image in green and the the benefit of
this is that you can use the same filter
all over the image to detect similar
features for example horizontal lines or
vertical lines
and that way these convolutional layers
are much more efficient than these dense
layers at the end and by applying
multiple and we can apply this multiple
times so filter again the filtered
images so here's an example just very
briefly let's say we have an image
that's dark here light there we can
apply a filter for vertical lines and we
can indeed see that there will be a
vertical line at the center but the idea
of a convolutional neural network is
that it will learn these things but
these the best type of filter by itself
so that's what we're using for this
image analysis um so just to give you a
quick preview here's an a picture of a
joint we apply a first layer of filters
so in fact we have ten different filters
out content filtered images we apply
another layer of 20 filters to these
filtered images again and then the final
layer with Ferdie filters and then when
you compress all of this information and
then we come to the conclusion yes
indeed there's a joint in it you can
actually see it's pop-up also in the
final layer so now you spur will take
you a bit through the technical
implementation exactly so this was only
theory I will show you how we
implemented this Apparel will be a quick
brief introduction to chaos and for some
people it might be just a second time
you can see everything at once so let's
have a look this was the sketch of the
the model we had and if we import
tensorflow
we can basically add an extra line of
code for every layer we have in our
model and as you can see we have three
convolutional layers at the top after
which we pull then we flatten things out
and at the end there's a dense section
okay let me now for I will just write
this a little bit more shortly on one
line to finish the model we need two
extra things we need a loss function and
the algorithm which optimizes or
optimizes the loss function
okay and that's that's all that's to it
so now we can fit our model to our train
images and evaluate on our test images
and this is the output we get so as you
can see it loops through 60,000 images
and then it performs an evaluation on
10000 test images and as you can see
we've got a loss of 0.2 well that
doesn't say a lot so vessel flow allows
us to add some metrics and metrics are
not necessary for training the model but
it will give us a better description of
the performance after it's straight so
the big difference between metrics and
the loss function is that for the loss
function has to be a differentiable
function but a metric can actually be
any function you want so we choose
accuracy and as you can see our accuracy
accuracy at the moment is 92% so 92% of
the images are classified with the right
label okay but now we're looking at all
the images just once during the training
process and it's actually possible to
loop over all the images multiple times
that's done with a box so let's just run
an 100 epochs and then the model will be
much better because it's seen a lot more
data or at least it's at more time to
converge to an optimal point but now the
problem is this will take long and well
we might be overfitting right because we
have no we don't see how the model is
performing during the training process
well so maybe that the loss function on
the train set is still going down but on
our validation said we might be we don't
know for this reason there are callback
there are also implemented in tensorflow
so you can just import a callback right
now we're implementing early stopping
and basically what it does is it monitor
it gives you call box gives you insight
in the performance of the model during
the training process and right now what
it does is it monitors the loss on the
validation set and when it's not
improving for five epochs after each
other
that's the patient's parameter then it
will already stop so maybe after five
fifty epochs
for this you need a validation set and
we don't have that yet so but we can
simply edit like this and that's all
that's true it's so it's just a quick
recap if you want to make a tensile flow
model you need an optimizer
for the loss function and if you want
you can add some metrics and to fit the
model you can choose the amount of books
you need make a validation set so the
callbacks can actually monitor the
training process I think that's it so
back to you
so yes were has just shown us the the
model that we're actually using for this
particular case of detecting insulation
joints with three convolutional layers
but maybe we want to do something more
complex or or something else so who have
you as I asked you already who's work
with convolutional neural networks who
of you knows about transfer learning so
I can see quite a few hands at the
pointer so I'll tell you also how we
what we do with transfer learning at at
Pro rail but first let me just tell you
what transfer learning is so let's
against that take a step back and look
at this convolutional neural network we
have a network here that can maybe
predict a bunch of different classes
let's say it's a network that has been
trained on lots of images and it can
predict all of these classes for
instance on the image net data data set
which has a
thousand types of images and fifty
million images or so we can actually use
the fact that these networks are very
good using a technique called transfer
learning and what you do there is you
would use this initial part of the
network a sort of a feature extractor so
this has been pre trained to extract
features from images to be able to make
classifications but maybe we we can
these features can also transfer to our
use case so you would use this first
part of the network and then discard the
latter part which actually is very
specific to the task at hand namely
classifying image net images and replace
that with another network which is
specific to our costs
so that would be classifying if there's
an insulation joint in there so what you
can do then is leave the initial part of
the network as is and only trained this
very last part of the network and by
doing this you don't need a huge amount
of data to train a very complex network
that has been felt very well thought
through by experts but you can still use
the power of this network and because
you need much less training data to just
make it work on your use case so that's
what we're actually doing also at global
but it doesn't always work well and let
me also tell you why but first before I
go there I forgot to show I also want to
show you how you can quickly actually
implement this in tensorflow
so we saw the model before and now we
just have to make one tiny change to it
so what we do here is instead of our own
network we start with a base model which
is the pre trained transfer learning
model and we say we import it directly
from tensorflow and we specify that the
weights have to come from image not so
this is a pre training model that has
been trained on imagenet and we say
include top is false so we discard the
final layers and the only thing that
we're constrained with is the input
shape of the images because we have to
turn our images into the same input
shape in order to make it work with this
network so then we can construct a model
which start with this base model and
then on top of that we can add our own
dense layers
and we can only train those for our
purpose so we can say model layers the
first layer the base model trainable is
fall so it won't Train the base layers
only the latter layers but why might it
fail
well imagenet data for instance captures
all kinds of classes car trucks cats
dogs those don't necessarily translate
well to our use case which is these
black and white images of just pure
railway track and we actually found that
initially it might not work that it
didn't work very well when we still had
a very small data set and our two
reasons for this first of all so these
features might not transfer well so what
you could do in that case are two things
you could open up the initial layers
also for training at a later stage so
you can fine-tune them so they better
match your datasets but then if your
data set is small you start overfitting
I'm very fast and the second thing is
you could cut back even more layer so
maybe only use the first two three four
five layers of the of the pre-training
network because those will extract more
basic features and not maybe features
that are specific to cats ears or
something we find out with the larger
data set and for more complex causes
there is actually use for us and
transfer learning so initially also our
use case once we had to detect 95% of
the joints and our simple model was
already sufficient for that so we just
needed a small pocketknife but now we
want to find more exclude more false
positives such as leaves on a tractor
which actually got classified false
positive so leaves are also bad and
trained tracking computer vision and
maybe we can do that with better with a
more extensive network or when we move
on to other types of data so classifying
degradation etc so that's it for the
model site and now yes per will tell you
how to deal with large sums of images
when training neural network exactly so
what we did before was we fitted a model
and just gave the whole training set to
the model at once
but the the problem with that is that
right now we have so many images that we
can count just load them in memory on
our machine so the load is too heavy and
well easy fix for that is that we're
gonna make small chunks of all the data
and we give all these small parts to the
the model separately which is possible
with tensorflow
of course how you do that how do you do
that we create an object for they which
is a data set and you can make a data
set with simple CSV with a generator or
iterator but right now we choose to list
all the files in a certain directory
what this gives is a list of all these
files and if you look carefully they are
sometimes in the directory with a zero
and sometimes in the directory with the
one so this whole list contains the
positives and the negatives but it the
data step the list is not created
directly itself this is just a reference
to all the two other than image data but
we're not interested in the file paths
we're actually interested in the images
itself so what we're doing now is we're
going to map a function over this data
set which is called pre process I've
wrote it down right here basically what
it's just it's just load it loads the
image and it also extracts the label and
combines them together so what we have
right now is a list of all the images a
very long list and it's not calculated
already but this is just a reference to
all the images okay a trick that's often
used in computer vision for creating
even more training data is that you
argumented data so when we have a
picture of a picture of a joint we can
flip it rotate it adjust the brightness
which will give us a lot of other
pictures of the installation joint and
in tension flow there are all these
transformations are already implemented
so it a few lines of code I can write a
function which I can also map over our
data set search that in a way that when
there is a picture with a certain
probability sometimes its flipped
sometimes it wrote sometimes the
brightest is adjusted okay now there are
a few other steps we're going to do
first of all it's also possible to
shuffle our data set and it's a little
bit different than you would expect
instead of shuffling all the images in
the whole list this method creates a
buffer of 200 images and then of the
first 200 images and then it will select
of one of those 200 as the first image
that it outputs then and not the image
201 is edits to our buffer and then from
those 200 pictures
the second big picture of our list is
created so it basically has a buffer in
memory and it samples out of this buffer
and the way you do that is by just
calling shuffle and you set the buffer
size for the more advanced tensorflow
users you can already think about what
what would be a more efficient time of
shuffling the data and we'll I'll come
back to that later so the second step is
we're going to create batches switch in
a way that we can deliver 32 images to
the model at once so that we're not
going to back propagate after every
image and these are basically the little
chunks we're feeding to our model so
we're not giving the whole list at once
but well it presents the first 32 images
and then the second 32 images etc and
then there's the last trick we use is we
repeat this minus one times which means
we repeat or this generates an infinite
amount of images because when we're
training we don't know how long we want
to train and now we can just fit our
model on this data by replacing the X
and y just with the data set and well
then we're done but now we've got
another problem
and that's the last thing we're going to
talk about in this talk and that's the
problem of combining the CPU with the
GPU the model right now is trained the
these batches are created by the CPU
which is much slower than the GPU which
is used for the training process so
basically our CPU can just cannot keep
up with our GPU so let's get back to the
code and I'll show you what the
situation is right now the first batch
is prepared by the CPU and effort that's
done the GPU starts training and the CPU
is doing nothing
so let's first fix that problem what we
want actually is that they run a
parallel so the CPU already starts
preparing the second batch
well the GPU is training on the first
batch and it's gaining you can just do
that with a simple line of code and
again adding a buffer so that maybe the
CPU as some yeah as some can have some
slack and this GPU never runs out of new
batches but if you have a closer look
when the CPU is preparing such a batch
it has to do 32 images after each other
but most computers have more CPUs so
we're going to use all of them and run
that in parallel
so the mem functions you see on the top
we can actually run them next to each
other and the machine we were using as
one GPU and twelve CPUs so we add a
parameter that says use twelve
yeah well work on twelve images in
parallel the last optimization is that
it in some at some point or in some
situations it can take some time to load
an image from well the server you're
working on we train our model remotely
and actually retrieving the images can
take some time well and you guessed it
also this can be done at parallel which
is one line of code which is called
interleaf and again we set the number of
parallel calls to 12 if you have no idea
what to do with this number then you can
just find our Bertrille error and look
what it does but you can also go to
outer pilots and just replace it all
with this tensorflow line and then
tensorflow will look during the training
time what's the best parameter for you
okay well let's just get back long time
because I gave you an exercise I was
wondering if somebody already solved it
otherwise I'll give you the answer as
you've seen this gives you a lot of
freedom creating a data set for your
neural network but there are sometimes
some small issues and the one I want to
address is that when you're creating a
buffer this buffer is sometimes quite
large if the objects in your buffer are
quite large so the the thing right now
is that we process the image before we
were going to shuffle it which is good
because we can maybe crop and resize the
image before we shuffle it so the images
in our buffer are smaller than the
original images
but if he shuffled all the way on the
top then we only shuffled the file pants
which are even even smaller than the
pictures so that would be a more
efficient way so well lots of things to
optimize we well first was possible to
increase our speed with we trained 10
times faster than we did before which
was great so what did we talk about we
showed you how we use computer vision at
pro rail which model you want to use and
at the end we showed you how you can
efficiently input the data into your
training process so now you've got all
the ingredients to solve our carrier
case we said all we gave all the data to
Google and if you visit this link you
can give you a try yourself
there's also a notebook included and
we'll set the slides on LinkedIn so you
can have a look at that and try it
yourself thanks for your attention
[Applause]